eu quero compartilhar com vocês um
segredo da natureza que é incorporar
plantas repelentes de mosquito no
ambiente de nossa casa integrar plantas
como Alecrim lavanda citronela e
melaleuca no ambiente doméstico pode ser
uma estratégia inteligente para ajudar a
afastar o mosquito da dengue essas
plantas são conhecidas por suas
propriedades repelentes naturais não só
contribuem para um ambiente mais
agradável aromático em casa mas também
atua como uma medida adicional contra o
aeds egípto que é o transmissor da
dengue pessoal lembre-se apesar dessas
plantas serem auxiliares valiosos elas
não são uma solução única o mosquito da
dengue é astuto ele se esconde em
lugares inimagináveis por isso além das
plantas Recomendo o uso de óleos
essenciais no difusor para espalhar
esses aromas repelentes pelo ambiente o
alecrim a lavanda a citronela e o
hortelã pimenta são ótimos Aliados nessa
batalha contra o mosquito